[Music]
on this Thursday night plans to address
the many failings in Canada's care homes
the proposed solutions
enough is enough really plus the help
wanted and needed right now in Quebec
and who's being blamed for a spike in
New Brunswick's bovid 19 cases a
heartbreaking consequence of this
pandemic the osprey boy the toll it's
taking on people struggling with
addiction mounting mayhem in Minneapolis
fury explodes over the unarmed black men
who died after an officer kneeled on his
neck and a reality check on Canada's new
gun ban why critics say it's missing the
target
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with what advocates hope is a
moment of reckoning for something that's
been ignored for years in this country
the failings of long-term care after
decades of neglect it's taken a pandemic
to finally put the problems inside our
care homes into sharp focus we're
stopping at nothing because the stakes
are too high we will do whatever it
takes in our power to protect our most
vulnerable seniors and ensure they get
the care they deserve
in Ontario after those disturbing
military reports about conditions inside
some care homes the province is now
sending out more inspectors and taking
control of seven hard-hit facilities in
Quebec officials are rolling out a major
recruitment campaign for more staff
after years of warnings about chronic
staff shortages long-term care is a
provincial responsibility but Canada's
deputy prime minister says improving it
is everyone's responsibility and all
options to reform it including ownership
structure she says are on the table all
options must be on the table when it
comes to how care for our elders will be
provided I think it is clear to us all
that root and branch reform is necessary
we need to act with speed but not haste
and work with our provincial partners
the Prime Minister is holding a
conference call this evening with the
premiers to talk about what can be done
David akin looks at some of the options
on the table we have a unanimous
unanimous position all the Premier's are
the different provinces indeed they
unanimously agree fixing long-term care
needs more money from Ottawa we want to
change the system a broken system that's
been around from for decades we need
money that's what it comes down to
we're telling mr. Trudeau if you really
want to help us in long-term care
facilities please increase your transfer
in help to all provinces but experts say
more money alone is not going to fix the
problem in addition
the federal government should draw up
legislation that will set national
guidelines and national standards for
all levels of care I think that we
actually have to start with something
that looks holistically at seniors care
because home care like long-term care
and retirement homes and assisted living
they are all part of the provision of
seniors care on Thursday the Canadian
Medical Association urged Ottawa to set
national standards on staffing levels
working conditions personal protective
equipment for staff and new reporting
and data collection so that different
jurisdictions can be compared we really
have a patchwork of approaches that
depend on the jurisdiction the province
the territory the federal NDP has
another fix ban for-profit long-term
care facilities in the for-profit model
of care for seniors there is more
emphasis on the bottom line than care
for seniors will the Liberal government
myth that there is no place for profit
when it comes to the care of our seniors
there is in fact some research that
shows in general terms some differences
in death rates and illness at for-profit
care centers versus those run by
nonprofits municipalities and charities
many of the outcomes that we're trying
to address with long term care are worse
in for-profit facilities but most
importantly for advocates and for
families is that this crisis finally
sparks some change this is our time of
reckoning this is actually the moment
where we have to focus on making sure
that it gets better
enough is enough really David akin
global news Ottawa any major fixes to
long-term care will take time and the
thing is lives are on the line right now
in Quebec some care homes are under so
much strain the premier has asked
soldiers deployed in them to stay until
September the defense minister says
that's likely not possible as Mike
Armstrong explains they just don't have
enough trained employees to fill the gap
he's already been turned down but
Quebec's premier isn't done asking for
us well ago has been told that for the
Canadian Armed Forces keeping the
soldiers working in residences isn't
sustainable but he says he'll be talking
to the Prime Minister about it in
Thursday evenings conference call with
the premiers because the soldiers are
too important to lose after June we need
them so what will they do if they go
away I guess they must have something
more important to do what it is it's not
a long-term solution it is speaking in a
UN online press conference Prime
Minister Trudeau today said the Army's
presence was always supposed to be
temporary they were a stopgap the
problem is that gap still exists more
than nine thousand two hundred workers
from long term care centres in Quebec
are still off the job due to kovat 19
while Quebec is hoping is to hold on to
the army until September 15th while it
finds and trains new employees 10,000
orderlies you know in life when you
don't think big you have nothing so we
are thinking big the first part of that
effort is international the province is
hoping to attract orderlies working in
other countries to move to Quebec that
campaign launches next week with a goal
of 550 for sure now the borders are
closed but Quebec government will be
ready when the borders will open the
second part of the plan is a hiring
bench the government is opening up
10,000 positions for orderlies starting
at 49 thousand dollars a year he can't
pay asking the school board
administrator says students wouldn't be
getting the normal amount of training
instead of 870 hours over seven months
it would be just 300 hours some of it on
the job that would get new people into
facilities as quickly as possible now
solving one problem is causing others
the new higher pay for orderlies throws
a lot of the provinces pay structures
out of whack nurses with years of
training would start at a lower salary
than a brand-new orderly Mike Armstrong
Global News Montreal there's been a
major setback
new brunswick restrictions are being
reimpose din the campbellton region
after a new outbreak of kovat 19 it's
linked to one health care worker who
officials believe contracted the virus
while on a personal trip to Quebec
officials say the person did not self
isolate when they got home instead the
person went to work and saw patients for
two weeks five other people have now
tested positive including another health
care worker officials warn there are
likely more cases or urging everyone in
the region to get tested I understand
this is very upsetting for the people of
this region we are focused on putting
out the fire determining who is carrying
the virus and isolating them as quickly
as possible to limit its spread further
in the community the hospital in the
city of campbellton has scaled back at
services as a precaution your Brunswick
premier says the initial case involving
the health care worker has now been
handed over to the RCMP to determine
whether charges are warranted there's a
worrying spike in cases in South Korea a
country that has managed to limit the
spread of cope in 1979 new cases were
reported today that's the highest number
in nearly eight weeks so public health
restrictions are being reimpose museums
parks and galleries will close for two
weeks businesses are being asked to
reintroduce flexible working hours and
bars clubs and sporting venues are being
advised to close most of the new cases
are connected to a distribution center
near Seoul health authorities say it's
becoming difficult to trace the
transmission routes of the new cases and
if the numbers keep rising stricter
quarantine measures in Korea will be
necessary anger and Minneapolis keeps
building over the death of an unarmed
black man after a white officer kneeled
on his neck the police chief says his
department has contributed to a deficit
of Hope George Floyd was pleading for
help and said he couldn't breathe before
he died thousands of people are
demanding the officers involved be
charged with murder there's been rioting
and looting windows smashed and
businesses set on fire Minnesota's
governor has activated the National
Guard one of the officers involved had
dozens of past complaints against him
that resulted in no disciplinary action
Jackson Cross Co reports the streets of
Minneapolis exploded in as
see of rage and grief as protesters set
their sights on a local police precinct
officers responded with tear gas and as
the night wore on things only got worse
sporadic looting broke out
then came the fire in the smoldering
ashes the city and an entire nation are
left searching for answers over the last
two days and the emotion ridden conflict
over last night is the result of so much
built-up anger and sadness those minutes
of horror saw 46 year old George Floyd
die in the hands of police
Floyd was arrested after being accused
of using a counterfeit $20 bill an
officer knelt on his neck while he
begged for mercy breathe by the time
Floyd was loaded onto a stretcher
paramedics were unable to find a pulse
everybody was saying stop I just don't
understand how could four officers
people that hired to protect this how
could they even let then how could they
be a part of it the four officers have
been fired there are calls including
from the city's mayor for criminal
charges I want to see the police Floyd's
death has ripped open a painfully
familiar wound in communities across the
u.s. we feel as if there was a knee on
all of our collective necks a knee that
says black life does not matter and as
protests spread across America there is
a collective sense of outrage and fear
that history will continue to repeat
itself
Jackson frost co Global News Washington
China has moved to assert full control
over Hong Kong through a new national
security law Canada is condemning it
tonight along with the United States
Australia and the UK saying the
legislation which bypassed Hong Kong's
parliament threatens civil liberties and
dramatically erodes Hong Kong's autonomy
- Parliament approved the bill in a
landslide vote it makes it a crime to
undermine Beijing's authority in the
territory could also see Chinese backed
security agencies set up in Hong Kong
for the first time since the former
British colony was handed over to China
the law sparked the first major
anti-government protests in Hong Kong in
months China says it's essential to
tackle growing violence and to benefit
the stability and prosperity of Hong
Kong a global financial hub
pro-democracy legislators though say it
is the end of Hong Kong as we know it
this month the beginning of a fat and
traumatising era to Hong Kong because
they've practically taken away our soul
our soul being the body within the
Treasury all these years
a Standing Committee of the Communist
Party will now draft the legislation and
the bill is expected to become law
before September when two crises
intersect coming up how the pandemic is
making an already bad situation worse
for people with addictions
one of the many side effects of this
pandemic is an increase in drug
overdoses especially opioid overdoses
physical distancing and isolation have
taken a huge toll on the mental health
of many people struggling with addiction
and has changed how they get treatment
and counseling heather Eurex west spoke
to some of the families caught in this
dual health crisis Shaun Richards began
March on a positive note
he was finishing a three-month
rehabilitation program for opioid
dependency and was regularly attending
Narcotics Anonymous meetings but by the
end of April Richards was dead I went to
Shawn's house because she had been in
touch with anybody and I found my son
passed from a fentanyl overdose Richards
had finished his rehab program just as
physical distancing measures began to
take effect his meetings went on line
and like so many Richards began to
isolate at home alone not being able to
see family or friends and said to me mom
I feel like I'm being backed up against
the wall we're in a really really
difficult moment because the Kovich
pandemic is intersecting with the opioid
crisis and some of the worst ways
possible while we don't yet know the
full impact physical distancing policies
have had on overdose rates the early
numbers are grim in March and April
British Columbia saw more than 230
overdose deaths its highest numbers in a
year in April overdose deaths in Toronto
hit a high not seen in three years and
between April and May overdose related
emergency room admissions in edmonton
rose from 9 to 14 a day with arriving
people haven't necessarily been able to
access or to use services at places like
this overdose prevention site in Red
Deer Alberta have remained open during
the pandemic but to ensure physical
distancing as possible capacity has been
cut in half as a result of the Turning
Point Society says fewer people are
using the service we have heard more
fatalities we don't have that data from
the coroner or anything yet but we have
heard of some an increase in fatalities
it's absolutely a heartbreaking
because I know that that could be my son
last month Angeles staines received the
phone call she feared most her son
Brandon Shaw had overdosed in Abbotsford
BC health officials have warned that
travel restrictions may be making the
street drug supply more toxic
fortunately Shaw wasn't alone when he
overdosed he was given a lock zone and
taken to hospital and he survived that's
something that haunts Joann Lok that
nobody had been there when her son had
taken that final fatal dose my boy yeah
I lost my son and I think he could have
been preventative things are opened up
jams
Heather Erik's West Global News Calgary
tomorrow Heather looks at how mental
health services are adapting to this new
reality and how to ensure safe supplies
of alternatives to illegal drugs
still ahead we delve into Canada's new
ban on guns what's it really aimed at
a firearm rights group is preparing a
legal challenge of the federal
government's ban on military-style
assault weapons the Canadian Coalition
for firearms rights hopes the sweeping
new rules will be struck down as
unlawful and beyond the scope of the
federal cabinet the changes were
promised by the Liberals during the last
election and they were implemented after
the mass murder in Nova Scotia last
month and Ipsos poll done exclusively
for global news shows 82 percent of
canadians approve of the ban on
military-grade assault weapons only 32
percent doubt it will reduce gun
violence
Mercedes Stevenson took a look at the
new rules which are complex to find out
which guns are covered by the ban and
which are not the Prime Minister's
announcement was a shot heard round the
world
effective immediately it is no longer
permitted to buy self transport import
or use military-grade assault weapons in
this country the move garnered
international headlines and struck a
chord with Canadians but what does it
actually mean experts define a
military-grade assault rifle as a gun
that can fire on fully automatic mode
militaries use it in war pull the
trigger and bullet spray out non-stop to
you're out of ammunition but that was
already prohibited in Canada so here's a
look at what changed the Liberal
government's ordering council bans
firearms based on bore width muzzle
energy or in some cases the name of the
gun how it looks or how popular the
firearm is it took my old duck gun and
it basically made it the same as a
rocket launcher
Mike Anderson trains military and police
on firearms his shotgun caught up in the
ban many other gun owners were afraid
theirs would be too so here's some
clarity
the new rules ban any firearm with a
bore diameter of 20 millimetres or
greater bore is the width of the barrel
of the gun and here's where much of the
confusion lies where is the barrel being
measured in some modern shotguns there
is a threaded barrel which is wider than
20 millimetres
to allow interchangeable parts so
hunters can change ammunition ducks take
a different caliber around than a moose
does the RCMP s firearms unit posted a
disclaimer on their website clarifying
its own rules you measure the bore
midway down the barrel of the gun not
the wider tip Public Safety Minister
Bill Blair insists most shotguns will
not be caught up in the 20 millimeter
rule Anderson says the new rules are
inconsistent and arbitrary meaning
Canadians can still legally purchase and
own guns that have the exact same
capability as other guns that are now
prohibited those two firearms have the
exact same capabilities yes
well ones banned because it's named yes
this one was specifically prohibited
allison de groot is the managing
director of the canadian sporting arms
and ammunition association she says
since the government banned the original
1500 firearms in early May hundreds more
have been added to the list and it just
keeps growing we are operating in this
completely foggy environment of whether
or not what we're doing is legal or
illegal in Canada gun control advocates
welcome the federal government's move as
a start but want an immediate buyback
program introduced to get firearms out
of circulation they also want tighter
rules to make sure gun makers can't
simply change the name of their product
to get around the prohibition now we
have to empty the pool and to be sure
that the faucet is tightly shut the
prime minister said the ultimate goal of
the ban is to make Canadians safer but
when it comes to gun crime
the majority of firearms deaths are
caused by handguns and so far the
government is leaving banning those up
to cities Mercedes Stevenson Global News
Ottawa
safety at new heights next the bc
attraction that's back in business a
popular tourist attraction in bc is back
in business the sea to sky gondola in
Squamish gives stunning views over how
sound but going up now requires new
protocols there will be reduced capacity
only every other cabin will be loaded to
allow staff time to sanitize them the
gondola had to close last year after
vandals cut the line causing millions of
dollars in damage and after all those
people hung out in a Toronto park last
weekend the city has decided to lay down
some markers pavement circles in Trinity
Bellwoods Park a way to give clear
visual guidelines on how to be in the
park safely it was crammed with people
last Saturday despite requirements for
physical distancing so these circles are
about three metres apart and they're big
enough we're told for two people to lie
down or three people to sit with their
legs crossed though it probably depends
how tall you are that is global national
for this Thursday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight see air canada is this field of
corn being planted near Lake Erie that's
near Port Burwell Ontario we'd love to
see your Canada please send your photos
we'd love to see them too viewers at
global national calm thanks for watching
I'll see you on Sunday at 7:00 for the
new reality take care of yourselves bye
bye
[Music]
you